la république
le conseil constitutionnel a constaté
que le scrutin du 15 juin 1969
vous conférez la majorité absolue par 11
millions 64 1371 voix sur 19 millions
7489 suffrages exprimés en vertu de
l'article 7 de la constitution qui
indique que le président de la
république est élu à la majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés au nom du conseil
constitutionnel j'ai eu l'honneur de
proclamer georges pompidou président de
la république française
mais de l'ordre national de la légion de
l'air
désigné par le peuple français ou exercé
la charge de président de la république
j'en prends officiellement possession je
vaux crée d'abord la personne du général
de gaulle c'est lui qui à doter notre
pays d'institutions grâce auquel nous
avons connu dix années de stabilité
bleeding dominé plusieurs crises
extrêmement grave et enfin assurer sans
secousses la transmission des pouvoirs
présidentiels tout au long de ces dix
années général de gaulle a ici
représenté la france avec un éclat et
une autorité sans pc
son exemple mon devoir mes tracés par
sont exempts comme il mais dictée par la
confiance que m'a manifestée le pays
j'ai la ferme intention de le remplir
dans le strict respect la constitution
de la vème république et avec la volonté
de maintenir la dignité de la france
président de la république on est un
homme comme les autres forcément là donc
j'ai même préoccupation et les mêmes
petits ennuis août les mêmes petites
joies que tout le monde et en même temps
on est toujours chef de l'état alors
vous me montrez en habit dans dés
réception solennelle ou dans des
circonstances officielles
mais si à ce moment là j'ai un soucis de
famille où elle simplement si j'ai un un
soulier qui me fait mal vous savez cela
me rappelle très bien je suis un homme
inversement inversement quand je suis à
la campagne et même si j'ai l'air de
prendre le soleil dans une chaise longue
et si je le prends d'ailleurs et avec
grand plaisir
eh bien je ne peux pas ne pas me
rappeler que je suis chef de l'état et
qu'à ce titre j'ai des responsabilités
que je ne peux déléguer à personne et
qui pèse sur bois en permanence
il à la barre
vous arrivez à vous personnellement plus
que moi
comme on dit
y'a pas de gagner
m
qu'ils me donnent le vertige comme ça
que de voir quelqu'un non écoute sans
vous sans plus moi je l'aurais pas pour
aller moi mais va se vanter de voir
quelqu'un pour moi c'est impressionnant
quand même si on pouvait si on voulait
tuer quelqu'un mais quelle poussée
non qu'est ce que ça peut faire cela
mais je veux voir le fond écouteurs et
on dit que je suis autoritaire ça moi
aussi autoritaire que pour ça
je suis bon je n'ai plus regardé à
l'hiver les sages c'est fou ça
maintenant à m allez va au delà par
seulement deux îles en mousse tu ne
reprend ici taclé le premier
ces programmes un des aspects les plus
difficiles à supporter dans la vie de
chef d'état et le responsable c'est
cette espèce de distance qui s'installe
entre vous et les autres et qui sauf en
famille tout de même grâce au ciel
existe toujours s'installe petit à petit
ce marque qu'on le sent on n'est pas
pour les autres
n'importe qui est ce qu on en souffre
moi j'en souffre est-ce que vous avez
essayé monsieur le président de réduire
cette distance et j'essaie le plus
possible
constamment j'essaie de me tenir au
contact et même de me mettre au niveau
si vous voulez de chacun je ne fait
d'ailleurs part parce que je déteste
tout ce qui va pas ça par an à la
solitude je le fais aussi au fond parce
qu'il me semble que si on veut bien
comprendre la vie et donc les gens et
donc la vie d'un pays
eh bien il faut essayer de se mettre un
peu à leur place et que si la distance
s'installe trop eh bien on ne se met
plus à la place de personne
et quand les vis-à-vis de l'extérieur et
notamment dans matière de politique
étrangère par cosco vis-à-vis des autres
pays ou leurs représentants
on est la france et ça dit
et notre attitude et vos paroles et vos
gestes et même cela conditionne votre
pensée excellence monsieur alassane
dramane des ambassadeurs du pérou
si l'ambassadeur c'est bien volontiers
que je reçois aujourd'hui les lettres
par lesquels le général juan velasco
alvarado vous accréditent aux prunes
loup comme ambassadeur extraordinaire et
plénipotentiaire du pays
en vérité il y a des moments où l'on
croit rêver voyons il ya trois semaines
j'ai vu monsieur waldeck rochet marché à
la tête d'une foule qui défilaient
derrière le drapeau rouge en tendant le
poids et en hurlant pour réclamer le
pouvoir
j'ai entendu les chefs de la cgt déclaré
que la grève était politique qu'elle
avait pour but de chasser le pouvoir
gaulliste c'est à dire le président de
la république vous avez élu le
gouvernement légal
j'ai vu j'ai entendu monsieur mitterrand
parlait comme s'il était le maître du
pays
il se débarrassait d'un revers de main
du président de la république
il exigeait contre la constitution la
démission du gouvernement légal il en
mettait à la place insurrectionnel donc
il fixait la composition dix membres
dont il désigne le chef monsieur mendès
france qui hélas pour lui s'est
précipité et monsieur mitterrand se
réservait la présidence de la république
tout cela
où l'avez vu vous l'avez entendu comme
et bien ces jours ci en suivant à la
télévision la campagne électorale j'ai
retrouvé ce même s'ils veulent décrocher
ce même monsieur mitterrand et je ne les
reconnaît pas ils sont devenu le
véritable agneau de pure démocrate
embrassant le drapeau tripple nous
voulons entendre parler d'arriver au
pouvoir que par les voies les plus légal
et encore demande-t-il simplement de
participer à un gouvernement avec
d'autres entre républicains s
comprendrait les français pour des naïfs
ce que je souhaite c'est que vous
sentiez
que de cette rencontre nous sommes
convenus que la coopération et l'amitié
entre la france et l'union soviétique
telles qu'elles résultent de l'histoire
de la géographie de l'action du général
de gaulle et l'action qui a été
poursuivie depuis et par les dirigeants
soviétiques et parle même
et bien cette politique de coopération
ira en s'étendant et en s'affaiblissant
pour je crois la satisfaction de nos
opinions publiques et pour la stabilité
en europe tout entier il ajoute que je
prélève m'a invité à faire une nouvelle
visite officielle en union soviétique et
que bien entendu je n'ai pas repousser
le principe tout en répondant et il a
bien voulu conduire c'était naturel
qu'il n'était pas possible aujourd'hui
d'en fixer le moment
il est essentiel de respecter la
solidarité politique c'est à dire
essentiellement la solidarité tous les
membres du gouvernement sur les grands
lits et grandes orientations de la
politique française telle qu'elle est
définie par le gouvernement et par mois
nous nous trouvons devant des années est
en tout cas une année qui saura bien
égard difficile cela peut nous étonner
par ce que nous avons vécu des années à
bien les égards d'une passivité
exceptionnel mêlant fin je comprends
très bien que devant les difficultés il
faille faire un retour sur soi même
devant ces difficultés nous ne devrons
pas vous ne devez pas courber l'échiné
laissez-passer attendre que l'orage vous
et avant de neil pas nous ne devons pas
non plus au jour le jour apte à ces
camps bien que mal la situation
en tout cas les éléments de telle ou
telle situation il faut que le
gouvernement et d'une politique il faut
qu'ils les tuent leur volonté il faut
qu'il est là présente à l'esprit quand
le gouvernent qu'en prévoyant et en
agissant